uh all right so guys here's my talk at
the table it's about worker burnout
and fatigue during the pandemic so last
month the jobs website
monster found 69 of employees reported
burnout while working from home
during the pandemic that is up 35
from may this comes as the national
unemployment rate fell to 10.2
in july which is still historically high
psychiatrist dr sue varma joins us now
to talk about the challenges
and how to stop the stigma surrounding
mental health
sue it's so good to see you thank you so
much for joining us let me ask you
right off the bat what is burnout what
is
work burnout and why do people feel more
vulnerable now
so burnout is this unique combination of
feeling
exhausted from your job having low
energy
having a negative mood or feeling
cynical about it
and not really feeling as if you have
efficacy or
agency or that your work matters anymore
and as you said you know two-thirds of
people are feeling this right now
and we're seeing that this is even more
so in the pandemic for a variety of
reasons we're not used to working
from home for this long and and and let
me say that there are some countries you
know in sweden they say that 30
of people work remotely and that's the
norm and that's the baseline
and trust me there's some people who
thrive but i have a lot of folks telling
me that this is
long and that they're missing the human
connection that they would normally get
so what causes burnout i sometimes get
the sense
that uh that the ground beneath me
is uneven like i'm sort of walking on
quicksand or on muddy
on a muddy ground like this the ground
is always shifting is that a way to you
know that's how i feel so
so what causes that feeling yes
so sometimes it's a feeling of uh that
there's more work
coming in that you can handle you know i
know that there are a lot of people who
are experiencing
a variety of family pressures whether it
be if you're at home and you're taking
care of a family and you're managing
remote learning
or maybe you're managing somebody who's
been sick in your family when
what's being thrown at you is more than
you can handle and that's really what
the definition when we talk about
workplace burnout and
you know i want to say that this is a
condition it's not necessarily a
disorder
it was recognized by the world health
organization earlier this year
and what we're seeing is that it is
unmanageable or
a stress that's not managed properly so
stress is normal we're all going to
experience
days where you know we feel like we're
burning the candle on both edges
but there's something about the quality
that we're not able to live up to or
meet the demands and a lot of times this
happens because our bosses
are employers they don't know what we're
contending with at home they're not
aware or maybe not sensitive to the
personal life aspect
and they're not making and we're not
making time for ourselves and taking
breaks
so all of this the external pressures at
work and then the personal demands
um you know there's not a balance and
there's an overflow in the system if you
will
you know we've talked about this before
sue i think where you know i told you
once that
what i try to do when i'm feeling
stressed is i think about the places
that i've been as a reporter
where i've seen people who are really
struggling with their situation who've
lived through
insurmountable tragedies and i think
about people who live through jim crow
or the great depression and i try to put
my life
in context to that but i don't know if
that's always the right thing to do to
look at somebody else or another
situation and say
well it's not as bad as that
yes it's a good point because for some
people and i'm glad that that works for
you and i think it does for some people
but for other people they say well you
know what it feels invalidating or it
feels minimizing
you know i know that you know if i
complain to my husband he'll be like but
you know what look at all these other
positive things
and sometimes what we need in that
moment is really someone to validate us
to empathize and to reassure us and to
be able to have
a conversation and that conversation
often should be with people that we work
with to say listen
this is what i have on my plate is there
any way that we can redistribute this
i'm going through a hard time right now
i think it's a lot it's hard for people
to say people want to show up and
especially in this pandemic when we
don't have
the daily check-ins i mean there were so
many built-in things that you could just
turn to a co-worker and say hey how
would you manage this
now it requires a phone call or a
meeting and so what i'm hearing is
people
saying that what they're missing with
the remote working is number one the
connections and the micro connections
that were built in you know the water
cooler conversations that you didn't
have to make an effort
or slacking someone on a work computer
system and really having an easy
dialogue
and they're missing what's also
interesting vlad is the commute
now i don't think anyone in a million
years would tell you oh i miss being on
the train
but we're finding that studies are
showing that being on the train
or having some sort of a commute even if
you're walking or biking to work
was allowed you emotional processing
time it was allowing you to get ready
for your day and then it was allowing
you to decompress
so you had these natural transitions
we're finding that people are working on
average an hour and a half to two hours
longer i know i was up on
my computer late last night and people
are sending you emails and we don't have
the same sort of boundaries because
our work day doesn't have a finite
ending the way it used to
that's a great point uh dr sue varma
thank you i encourage our viewers to
check out your
instagram your social media you always
have words of wisdom
there thank you very much sue we
appreciate it